[Music]
let's go to elizabeth in newport oregon
hey elizabeth what's going on
uh hi dr dalonia it's an honor to talk
to you it is more of an honor to talk to
you i promise how's it going
oh it's
it's going better than it i deserve
excellent excellent so what's up how can
i help okay um so
geez this gets pretty complicated okay
um so i'll uh just kind of start with my
questions
um i'm uh dealing with
quite a bit of regret following a
divorce
um
and i'm also
having issues
dealing with now that i am divorced um
the thought of having children i
basically got a second chance to have
children if i wanted them
um so that's
yeah
so how long you've been divorced
um less less than a year okay why'd you
get divorced
uh well some brief context um i'm a long
time ramsay listener um i'm debt free
and uh this is basically
a whole year of gazelle intensity like
all coming in at once all coming down at
once
basically starting in 2019 my mother and
brother both passed away both from
mental illness and addiction and right
in the middle of that is when my divorce
was going down
um
well what precipitated that divorce
somebody cheat on somebody you all said
you didn't like each other anymore what
was it oh god it was a messy
i guess the biggest thing with the
divorce was like i mean we we'd go on
through a bunch of things and then
what was it what was it what was it
you've got like there's like two things
what are they
um well
i would say the biggest issue is
probably like
my severe body dysmorphia okay
um
and then just
our just our inability like we did
everything wrong basically all
everything that you know dave ramsey
talks i mean you guys talk about it too
like we moved in together before we were
married we got a house before we were
married we had that like we didn't
combine finances like it was all and i
went head to head with my in-laws a
bunch of times which is stupid like i
learned a lot of lessons like so there's
just a lot of pressure on this
relationship early on and then in the
middle of it's a lot of grief and if you
grow up in a home where you've got a
mother with
with
mental health challenges and your
brother's got mental health challenges
and there's addiction then um
you may have picked up some
different pictures and different models
that weren't healthy
and
not to mention whatever genetic
components and all that stuff whatever
abuse and stuff you suffered and so
there was a lot of pressure on this
thing and you
said i didn't take a break
is that right or i'm out
or he said i'm out
and we both i mean we both did like he
basically when we were talking about
divorce like he offered to reconcile and
i just said no and then a couple months
into that the separation i tried to
reconcile twice and he said no so then
we like just went through with it and
then i sold my house
paid off my debt bought a van moved
across the country like literally to the
west coast from new york
uh
and lived in the van off-grid for four
months i've been living in awkward for
four months in a van
down by a river please say yes please
say yes literally
literally really that's fantastic
literally down by a river elizabeth yes
i'm gonna start calling you matt foley
all right so
um
there's an old saying in
counseling
which is the tyranny of accomplishing
all of your dreams
right um and
you're not accomplishing all of your
dreams but
kind of one of the worst things that
happens when we make major life changes
whether that's taking a new job
cheating on our spouses with somebody
who finally is acknowledging that that
we're good looking or that we're lovable
or that they make us feel sexy again or
moving across the country in a van down
by a river whatever the thing is paying
off all of your debts whatever the thing
is
what catches
millions of people off guard
is that when you reach these new
milestones
you go with you
yeah and you
experienced
deep tragedy and if you grew up in the
house of an addict or somebody with
mental health challenges you also grew
up not liking your mom sometimes
probably hating your mom sometimes
and then you have to reconcile that with
the grief you feel because your mom died
and then you've got that guilt on top of
you and then your brother and all those
things and i should have said i could
haves and here we are in this grief and
now my in-laws are idiots and my husband
and i
are
just
stumbling through this thing right
and i'm just gonna run and the problem
is
you showed up in that van down by the
river on the west coast right
yeah and he came with me in my brain
like yeah like all of this regret is
basically as i do a lot of dream
recording i pay attention to my dreams
and like i get these just invasive
persistent dreams about marriage and
like
it's almost brought me to the point
where i reached out to him to see you
know to try again but like who wants
that phone call like i don't want to be
you know the ex that calls you back like
i just don't feel that would be
appropriate like we had as many reasons
to
to continue the divorce as to stay
together like there were so many things
and like now yeah i don't see i don't
buy that
you all chose to get divorced and
when it comes to reasons and things i
mean
i just seen couples work through the
most insane things
and so you can point to it's because of
this it's because of this it's because
of this but the end of the day
it was because you don't want to be with
that person anymore
and so it's like well it's not like a
teeter-totter or like a scale where
you're like well there's just many
reasons to stay and this many reasons no
you just left and he left
and so
it sounds to me like you are desperately
painfully
and probably pathologically lonely
and you're exhausted
definitely that one and you are scared
and you are completely and totally alone
and
you may have gotten divorced because you
were in the middle of a hurricane and
you just left home like i got to get out
of here
and now the hurricane has passed and
you're coming you're interested in going
back and see if your home's still
standing all that stuff's
i mean that you're not crazy
and you're not wrong and who wants that
phone call he may desperately be
dreaming of that phone call
or you may be making that phone call
because you're desperate
either way what i would tell you is in
this moment in history be true to
yourself
and if you miss him call him and say i
miss you
if it wasn't abusive if it wasn't
violent if it wasn't those things that
um where you are codependent and
um
you know what i mean it sounds like you
all left on weird terms like you still
love the guy and he still loves you and
y'all just found yourself on a train
moving west and you just didn't get off
it's
something i mean it's true but like so
much because i've basically been
doing so much research on marriage and
family and everything in the last year
and like if i knew then what i know now
about marriage how my opinions about
marriage have changed like i would have
tried way harder
and some of this may be grief some of
this may be
guilt
some of it may be regret
and it may be less connected to him and
more connected to you
uh it sure could be
other this other question that i
struggle so much with with this whole
divorce is like we were 100 on the same
page 100 on the same page about not
having children and like that sort of
changed for me now a little so i got
this like whole opportunity to like have
kids again if i wanted but
my i come from a family of like
borderline personality disorder
agoraphobia obesity like opiate
addiction alcoholism and like i am like
i'm afraid to like how does a person
know if they're too crazy to have
children like is that a
like
i don't that's that's what i struggle
with a lot too because i'm 36 like i
could easily have another relationship
and like
are you too crazy to have children
i
would love to find out
it seems so easy to screw up children
like
one of the best ways you can
one of the best ways you can love and
honor children
is by first loving and honoring yourself
okay and by being well
and by doing the work to be well what
you've done over the last year is you
ran
and i'm not gonna say running in your
situation wasn't the right thing
you have not dealt at all with elizabeth
you've read some books
you have got some new information you've
thought about a lot of things
and you're literally in a van down by a
river
what you haven't done
is learn how to be in relationship
and new information is helpful it's
really helpful
but it won't heal you it just helps you
it's like a gps system it helps you find
the right road but you got to walk that
road
and that is relationship
and what you don't have a model for in
your family history
is how to do relationship how to be at
peace how to be well
for sure and you've got a lot of
childhood trauma as my guess you've got
a lot of adult trauma is my guess
turned out yeah
and
that's okay your past is not gonna
determine your future if you don't want
it to
is it gonna be hard oh my gosh yes
are you gonna have to work really hard
to get new models and to get new
relationships and to practice
living healthy a healthy life in a way
that you've never even seen done before
yeah you are
and by the way you're allowed to make
wild intense proclamations when you're
28 and change your mind when you're 29.
that
happens
i'm never having kids
that's what it was basically yeah and
then you hold your first kid with your
buddy has a kid
and you go
oh yeah
yeah you know what i mean
or i'm never moving to that town because
that town suit and i live in that town
um i love the way esther perel says it
she says most adults will have three or
four
deep loves in their lifetime and if they
work really really hard it'll be with
the same person and personally right i'm
actually fan first yes i've heard that
and so what you what happened is
y'all stopped working at it
yeah
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to immediately
today
reach out to somebody
whether that's a counselor whether
that's at
betterhelp.com
whether that's a local pastor
whether that's a mentor or a friend
and i want you to say the words
i need to learn how to be in
relationship with somebody
okay
and if you miss your ex-husband call him
you're 2500 miles apart or 6 000 or
wherever i don't know where you all are
you're way far apart from each other and
the worst he can say is i don't want to
talk to you
i've moved on i'm married to somebody
else
all of that relationship is a risk
but what you're doing is you're making
yourself a little bit bonkers with the
unknown
am i too crazy to have a kid should i
have gotten divorced but
just move forward
with healing
just move forward with
hey how are you man
how's it going
i miss you just want you to know
and he may say
you're bananas or he may say i've been
waiting for this phone call for however
many months and it's probably honestly
it's probably
um
i don't i don't even want to guess i
didn't want to guess you had so much
trauma in 2019
and you had so much trauma leading up to
2019 and then we've had 2020 in 2021
again you had a divorce in the middle of
that in unsupportive in-laws and your
own mental health challenges and your
own addiction challenges
i don't there's so much going on a lot
yeah
actually you know what i'm gonna
i know the uh the the internet warriors
are gonna
be mad at me i'm gonna tell you to pause
for a second before you call him
i want you to call a counselor first and
sit down and talk to somebody
okay for the first time and i want you
to
if you can at all stop living in a van
down by a river go get an apartment
and get a full-time job and work real
hard
and start reconnecting with people
start reconnecting with human beings and
be in a relationship with them
and this is going to be hard
and if you can get with a counselor who
will walk through this with you or a
great mentor that you trust and someone
is going to hold you accountable and
call you on your crap and isn't going to
let you just be like yeah you go girl no
that's going to say
that's not how we talk to people
and it may be that you end up in a
medical doctor's office
to get some medical care
and to get a team of people who can help
and by the way this is expensive and i
know that i'm not behind the sky
someone's listening to this saying i
don't have that kind of money i get that
it's hard
there are resources out there for you if
you want to if you want that healing and
they are hard to find
um
but i'll tell you this elizabeth and
i'll say to everybody else listening
you're worth finding those things
to answer the question am i too crazy to
have a baby i can't answer that
i can't answer that
um
i've seen people become extraordinary
and remarkable and powerful
when they're holding kids and i've seen
really brilliant wonderful people have
kids and they just regress and become
four-year-olds themselves and so that
question is hard and so i'm never gonna
just make a blanket statement like that
i will tell you you're worth healing
and you're worth
staring down that generation terry reel
calls it a forest fire of dysfunction
that is raged through your family
for generations now
and somebody has to have the courage to
turn and face that forest fire and say
it stops with me and elizabeth that
could be you
that can be you
and it will be hard and the goal here is
if you do have kids that their road is
easier to walk than yours is
because you're saying no more
and if you don't have kids you're still
worth it
you're still worth it and if you made a
mistake call him
after you've done some relational work
and you've got a chance to breathe and
you're not sleeping in a van call him
and say hey i miss you but that's for
down the road a little bit
down the road
i love it when when in my life when i
look in the mirror and say i was wrong i
need to go fix that i love that i love
that
every what's the old meditation thing
every moment is a chance to every time i
have a breath
i have a chance to say on gonna start
over and i'm gonna start over and i'm
gonna start over
i'm proud of you for making the call
elizabeth now i'm gonna be really proud
of you because it's time for you to be
courageous and go do the hard healing
stuff